today is january 4th monday and we are
so excited to welcome the newest member
of our team to eight news now
our new co-anchor we have christian
joining us today for his first day on
air and he'll be joining us
every day from here on out
and you're going to get to know them and
we thought it might be kind of fun if we
did some like rapid fire questions
so some of the quirkier questions you
could get to know
uh the real christians so you up for
this christian
of course i'm very excited to be here
very excited to be joining the team so
uh ask away okay sir all right
all right number one describe yourself
in three words
three words very difficult but i think
one uh passionate i love what i do so
i'm i'm 100
into every single thing that i do at
work or outside of work so i would say
passionate
uh two i would say loyal um you will
find out that
everything that i do i am 100
invested as i am like you know being
passionate about it and number three i
think
would be curious i'm very curious
obviously that's why i'm a journalist so
i love asking questions and finding
answers so i would say
passionate loyal and curious would be my
three words all right that works
fantastically
all right favorite destination for
vacations
favorite destination that i've been to
in the past i would have to say key west
um i love the fact that i don't get cell
service out there so it's completely you
just
tune out out of everything amazing views
uh for those who haven't been there i
mean you can just turn from
side to side and you will see the ocean
it's just peace and quiet
yeah and of course the food is delicious
yeah oh my gosh yeah
food ocean take me there well if you
could go anywhere in the world
christian where would that be and why
i would say egypt since i was a little
boy
i've always been curious about going to
egypt i love
the history i love the culture i love
just the um the buildings the people
itself from what i've been reading
throughout the years i am very curious
to be there and experience it firsthand
um i had an opportunity years ago and at
the last minute things kind of cancelled
out so
hopefully one day you know it's it's on
my bucket list oh yeah you're young okay
so that's on your bucket list
what else is on your bucket list i think
the other thing that's on my bucket list
is um to own a home
uh i've traveled so much in my career
and i feel like a gypsy in
in some way i've been bouncing around
throughout the country and i feel like
it's time for me to settle down and buy
a home and just
you know make some routes and obviously
las vegas is the perfect place right
it really is christian and yes with our
business as people
come and go you'll find that once you
find home
you find home and you do buy that home
and of course you know
i've been here eight years now 25 years
in the business and
um yeah we want you to know that this is
home for you so go buy that home work
towards that christian i like that i
like that's on your list
i'll keep you posted okay good you know
i'll help you with that too
all right so if you were not a
journalist um i always said my other
career choice would have been a homicide
detective but if you weren't a
journalist what do you think you would
be
you know i think i if i didn't have to
work
and do what i do i mean i love being a
journalist but i think
on my spare time if i had the time i
would find
something related to animals whether it
be working at a zoo maybe at an animal
shelter
i think i would find a way to maybe
provide every single animal out there
whether it's a cat a dog
a reptile or whatever a home it just
breaks my heart just seeing animals that
are just locked in cages and
you know i'm a big obviously i'm a big
animal lover so
if i could help and do my part to get
those
uh little guys home somewhere i think
that is just
you know the best job ever in the world
yeah
yeah you've got a big heart there
christian
all right what's your favorite hobby my
favorite hobby
i would say is making puzzles
uh since i was a little boy i've always
been
uh exposed to just different puzzles
from either like
a 50 piece puzzle to like a thousand
piece puzzle
um you could find puzzles throughout
like my family's
you know kitchen table dining table
everywhere i mean
there's just i mean and it's not just
like of any specific
design or whatnot but it's just a matter
of just me having some sort of like
challenge and then just finding all the
pieces and putting it together very
similar i think
to what a journalist is all about
because you have to go out and find all
the pieces and then put the story
together
so i would say puzzles if anyone has any
good puzzles out there any good
recommendations
and they have to be regular standard
puzzles because i've tried the 3d ones
i'm not a problem yeah yeah that creates
i'm not a pro christian yeah stay away
from those
all right morning or a night person i
think i'm a night person
i feel i can get definitely more done
during the day
if i just focus uh on work at night i
can get my workout i can
do my errands uh get a good meal in and
then just kind of focus on work
for the second part of the day so
definitely a night person all right
these ones we're gonna do like one
answer things you don't even need to
explain
all right what is the one thing that
annoys you the most
the one thing that annoys me the most i
think
when people are chewing gum and they
open their mouth
got it what's the strangest thing you've
ever eaten
strangest thing that i've ever eaten is
duck liver
oh yeah yeah i got you there all right
what's the first thing you do when you
get up in the morning
i pray very thankful very nice
very nice if you could get yourself
anything
what would you get if i could get myself
anything what would i get i think i
would just get
peace and economic
just satisfaction for my family
what is your biggest addiction my
biggest addiction
please please please don't tell anyone
but it's chocolate chip cookies
i i can't you put a cookie in front of
me it will disappear
all right here's a funny one what tv
sitcom family
would you be a member of if you could
i think friends uh i know that that was
a little bit more towards
the later part of my years but i think
friends because i can
um identify in so many ways obviously
being a journalist and just kind of
going cross-country
and working i think friends is like the
ultimate thing okay
how long does it take you to get ready
in the morning uh-huh
well i could tell you that it takes me
15 minutes but i think in a
reality it's about an hour
it takes 15 minutes for me to go
anywhere get ready but it's got it it's
more or less about an hour
all right what is your go-to place to
shop whether it's for you know
toiletries or groceries what's your shop
place
costco very good very good for one thing
and i end up coming out with a whole
cart full of stuff of course i know it
right
all right what is your least favorite
beverage
i would say soda and i would say
within the soda family i would probably
say root beer okay
i can't believe you don't like root beer
christian
i've tried i've really really tried what
is the lowest grade you have ever
received in a class and what was it for
i'm gonna be honest with you i'm not
gonna lie i did get an f and it was in a
religion class
but it was in my defense it was
a english class using the bible
for literature and me being catholic and
growing up in a private school setting
i couldn't it was very hard for me to
kind of uh
set aside the religion part of the
actual bible so
i really struggled there with my teacher
and i ended up dropping out
oh that's okay it happens it happens
christian thank you for sharing that
what compliment do people give you the
most
i think the biggest compliment that
people tell me is about my teeth
i'm very very shy about them because i
think i have really really big teeth
uh but somehow people think that i have
a really nice smile so
i'll let you be the judge of that yes
you do you do christian
what is your least favorite type of
music
lee's favorite type of music i think
would be trans
um i love a good beat obviously being
latin i love
music but for some reason trans i can't
figure it out because i feel like
there's no
ending there's no words so the music
just keeps going and going and you're
dancing and
i just feel like when is this going to
be over and transition to the next song
all right so you won't be going to edc
anytime soon we'd have to drag you there
i guess
all right two last ones if you want a
million bucks what's the first thing you
would buy
i think the first thing i would buy
would be a home for myself
and then i would uh obviously buy a home
for my parents and my family
very nice and kind of a wacky thing but
how do you like your steak cooked
i would have to say medium rare i really
like it juicy so
all right we have so many great steak
restaurants in this town
so good good good to know all right this
was just fun kind of wacky thing to do
christian
so of course um it kind of gave people a
little behind the scenes on you
and they're gonna watch your first debut
here at channel 8 at 4 o'clock this
afternoon so
christian you and i will get back to
work and thanks to our viewers for
checking this out
yeah i'm very excited hopefully you guys
will tune in and watch